we're here when the quarterbacks and the
other players are here justin herbert
out of the blue plops down had a nice
conversation with him following our
extended
uh excerpts from the joe burrow press
conference we try to get joe burrow he's
not doing anything other than the podium
right i i spoke to his people last week
they're doing nothing other than the
podium and you know he's the guy who's
got the hay in the barn at the top of
the process why do anything more he had
done some media
and there was some stuff that didn't
necessarily harmonize about what the
plan is and what the preferences are as
it relates to the cincinnati bengals he
addressed some of that today he was
asked about playing for the bengals if
drafted by the bengals he said well i'm
not going to not show up joe burrow
right now
i'm not going to not show up right i'm
still going to do i thought he wasn't
doing media i'm stuck they told me he
wasn't doing meetings maybe it's
something
because we were the ones who had
really been
pointing out the discrepancy between
things he had said things that carson
palmer said things that joe burrows said
to dan patrick he said that you want to
be the first overall pick but you want
to play for a team that is committed to
winning that came just days after carson
palmer had said the bengals aren't
committed to winning he seemed to put a
lot of that to rest as it relates to his
willingness to submit to the process and
i've seen some people
on social media who are reporters who i
would think know better than what they
have said right for joe burrow to come
out at his press conference and say
i'm going to submit to the process i'm
going to play for whoever picks me that
doesn't mean he wants to play for a
given team sure he's just accepted the
fact that he has to go wherever he's
picked because what's the alternative
you know if you're the first overall
pick you're not going to say no to 36
million dollars over four years fully
guaranteed you're going to go there that
doesn't mean in his heart that he's not
maybe hoping right that it works out a
different way right that's two different
things all together yeah well and either
way i thought he handled this press
conference you know very very well he's
phenomenal in those settings he really
is and that's he's going to check all
the boxes off the field along with
checking just about everyone on the
field too and that's what's going to
make him the slam dunk number one pick
i'm glad he answered it the way he did
you know you know he even tried to say
you know the one reason i didn't just
come out definitively and say oh yeah i
want to play for them he goes i didn't
want to sound presumptuous like i
definitely was going to be the number
one pick so i think at least he
silenced some of the murmurs now we're
going to get more of a feel for this as
we continue to go on too because we'll
hear you know after he meets after the
combine and his representatives get to
meet with the bengals and there starts
to get conversations we'll start to hear
some of the rumors about how comfortable
maybe he is with the bangles and so on
and we'll see where it goes from there
and that's the art here you can't come
out and say unless you're prepared to
see it through and sit out if need be
right you can't come out and say i'm not
going to play for the team that drafts
me and quarterbacks really do have
leverage i was intrigued by one of his
comments he was asked about when he said
last week that he has leverage he said
he was talking about the scouting
combine and working out and he's not
going to work out this week well that's
really not leveraging right as it
relates to the process right you don't
work out a lot of guys don't work out
that's not an exercise of leverage
that's a personal choice
i just i personally believe and i think
one of the frankly one of the reasons he
may not be sitting here with us is he's
going to face questions like this from
us if he was here
i think deep down there is a concern
that he knows there's nothing he can do
anything about for now he can't do
anything about it especially for now and
ultimately he can't do anything about it
other than maybe hope that you can plant
a seed of doubt in the team that has the
first overall picks mind that maybe it's
not in their best interest to bring a
guy who may not be all in because you
need your quarterback to be all in we
talked about that earlier in the show
yeah he needs to show up early stay late
be a leader hold people accountable he
has to want to be there and be the
leader of that team if he's reluctant
it's not going to work for anybody and
that may be the message that based upon
what he sees and hears and learns he may
send in subtle or not so subtle fashion
to the bengals if it comes to that so i
guess my broader point is this what he
said today doesn't matter it does not
end this question whether he hopes deep
down right they don't take him that is
not resolved and anybody who says it is
wrong i can understand bengals fans
sanded people in the media who i would
like to think are smart enough to
understand the distinction some of them
aren't aren't seeing it whether they're
doing that on purpose to pander to
bengals fans or not is a different issue
but there are two different questions
here yeah there is two different
questions you know at the very least you
can be impressed by what we saw there um
this has a lot of story left to be
written here certainly
um i think what also plays into the
angle is something you've mentioned a
lot the fact that he's working with you
know carson palmer's brother and uh
carson palmer of course did not have a
great marriage with the cincinnati
bengals i think that leads us to more
questions because we think that the
palmer family is probably telling joe
burrow more the dysfunctional things
that went on in the bengals organization
that maybe we're not aware of but of
course carson palmer is so those are the
things that we're going to see going
forward and yeah i think this is still a
very
early in this process and this will be
the first chance for zach taylor to sell
himself uh to
to joe burrow to say listen like there's
something to be excited about i know
offensive football i'm a young guy we'll
grow together and you know kick some
butt together that way too and whether
joe burrow and his camp buys it or that
yet that's and i'm glad you put it that
way yeah because we are conditioned to
believe and we just had a kid here
justin herbert on set who talked about
what an honor it is to be here justin
it's not an honor to be here they see
value in these guys they see benefit
they see the potential to make a lot of
money and win a lot of football games
with these players justin herbert has
earned this honor this is not an honor
per se it's a job interview where there
needs to be more of the teams selling
themselves to the players than it than
the players selling themselves to the
team especially for the guys who have
leverage as joe burrow said the guy if
it's a quarterback and he's not all in
you got to sell yourself to him to get
him to be all in with your team well
that's part of what the bengals need to
do you're right all right so you go
through the draft though how many guys
really have leverage like i look at it
right now i just really really want to
say like the only those are the only two
guys right chase young and joe has some
just from the standpoint if you're a
quarterback if you're a high first round
quarterback yeah and you don't want to
be with the team
and they get the impression you don't
want to be with the team that's a
problem yeah so those guys have leverage
but you have to use it in subtle ways
and i think that's may that may be why
burrow said what he said look yeah yeah
i think maybe the the horse started to
get a little too far
out of the barn or the cart got in front
of the horse or whatever stupid cliche
i'm trying to say right i think that
there's a subtlety and a nuance to
pulling this off to get a team to not
draft you and it became too big of a
story and it's really not all that
complicated he says i'll play for
whoever picks me carson palmer says the
bengals aren't committed to winning he
hires jordan palmer to
coach him and then he tells dan patrick
i want to be the number one overall pick
but
i want to play for a team that's
committed to winning yeah right those
full circles pretty clearly those
questions are two different answers
today doesn't change
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports